well from domestic politics we can turn
to ukraine now because president
zielinski says only a negotiated
settlement can end the war in his
country the final stand in mariopol
seems to have been defeated and russian
forces have intensified their attacks in
the south and east of ukraine meanwhile
the u.s has authorized 40 billion
dollars of aid to ukraine half of it to
military supplies as the war looks to
continue for some time yet
we can hear from ukraine now and speak
to the ukrainian mp lisa yasko thank you
so much for being with us uh today and
can you just explain to us what the
situation on the ground is like where
you are
good morning well i'm currently
traveling to the was a world economic
forum
but the situation in ukraine is uh still
very sad it's already three months of
the war and people are very desperate
the fighting mood is still very very
high but the traumas and traumatized
situations that we all got from all of
that are only increasing
many people lost their jobs
the economic situation is very hard of
course many lost their
relatives their friends
and it's going on and um
the news that we hear today that russia
for example is using two-thirds of its
military submarines right now with the
with the rackets
they are right now in the sea is very
warning and uh
it's very sad that we all got used to
the fact that there are sirenas and the
warnings the air air warnings every day
and many people
see their normal life
as as
with this sounds but it's not normal and
we need to change that
we've um seen a situation where the
russians have finally taken mario paul
after that extraordinary defense that
was waged there including at the steel
works but now of course it means they
can really focus their attention on the
east and in the donbass region
how is the fighting there
it's very harsh
and tough
for many people it's very hard to get
any connection with the
sons with their brothers or their
husbands who are fighting there right
now in our military there is almost no
connection still there is
like thousands of people who are under
attack on everyday basis without food
without water
many are
taken forcefully to russia
we know that the forest migration is
taking place and the children are
kidnapped
women are raped
um unfortunately the situation didn't
become better and
it actually got worse because now we
know more about the numbers so now we
understand that uh it's a matter of of
our
persistence and our fighting mood and
there is no way back we need to win it
all we need to
have peace there and it we need to have
our territories back and we need your
help i mean the help of the
international
community of course to make it happen
that's interesting just to clarify then
the ukrainian positions still that
there'll be no territory given up to
russia
we're not going to give any territory to
russia that there cannot be any
compromise on that especially with that
thousands of numbers of victims that we
currently have of civilians and and the
military
uh and our army we're not going to
forgive this and uh it's not even in in
the discussion
okay okay and what what is the status of
crimea in that discussion
well we
we believe that we can bring crimea back
uh and our victory will only depend when
all our territories will be back because
now putin is uh
completely in a crazy
uh
mood and we understand that he is using
all his force to
destroy ukraine and for us it's a very
existential question we need to have our
territories back because we already paid
very high price for it and we will go
till the end to have our territories
back
do you think this is a war that you can
win given the size of the russian
military
well i think
in the world it's very hard to win
because there are always victims and
something that you lose and it's very
painful and that's something that will
remember for
maybe like hundreds of years in in the
future
uh but of course talking about our
freedom uh and our peace and our
territory there is no other way just the
victory because we are not going to be
slaves
it's not
acceptable for us
we are very freedom loving nation and we
will go till the end still the full
victory with this
wow and what help do you need from the
international community you spoke a
little bit earlier in the interview
about needing more
well of course it's about military
assistance and it's about economic
assistance right now and we need more
and more sanctions on russia to isolate
russia so that russia gets less money to
finance its work crimes in in ukraine
and
we need it very very quickly
because
as we see three months have already
passed and we could stop it much earlier
but russia still has resources to have
war in ukraine we need to do everything
possible to make sure that russia
doesn't have resources for that enemy
are you talking about those resources
and of course a lot of them come from
the sale of oil and gas particularly to
countries in europe don't they
exactly and it's very sad when we still
have some dialects with some european
countries discussing uh oil and gas
embargo while we are losing lives of
people every day and someone is is
scared to lose
some money from that but we are sure
that the business as usual is not
acceptable anymore the world is
different right now and it's a matter of
time only when we will have the new
reality and one more thing that is very
important we need to change the
international order i'm now talking
about the international organizations
and the tools that we may have to stop
the war and to have peace in the future
united nations council of europe other
organizations they need to have real
tools not just on paper but real tools
that will ensure that we will not have
war in ukraine or in other european
countries
in the future anymore
now women and girls are so often you
know the victims of war and we've
certainly seen that in ukraine and if
i'm being honest you know the some of
the stories
about you know the rape and the
treatment of children as well coming out
of your country have been some of the
hardest that i've ever covered as a
journalist with no doubt it's very
tempting to look the other way but it
does feel like we have to bear witness
can you share any of the individual
stories that you've heard
since this war just to give our viewers
a bit of a sense of what is happening
well one of my colleagues lost her
husband and they have two children um he
was killed uh
i also know uh people who are in kiev uh
obviously who were living in cave of
blessed who were raped and currently are
pregnant or uh
with very strong psychological traumas
but the numbers of these people are
thousands and i know that the hotline uh
receives like lots of calls
every day from people who are in need
but even those who didn't suffer so much
we all need that because life for us is
completely different for me for example
it's very hard to have
any happy moments because every every
second i know that there is a war in my
country and i cannot afford having any
positive moments but what's to do with
those who for example wear rape in front
of the
eyes of their children
or
they lost their children and we know
that there is a real nightmare of that
were crimes that were happening because
the rapes were happening not only to
women but also to children and to
elderly and simultaneously and i have no
idea who are those people who were
raised this way who were thinking that
raping
this way
so wide scale widespread is normal can
you imagine what is happening in the
brain of these people and it's a
big big tragedy and big question that i
believe we need to address as
international community how did it
happen there are so many people
in russia in the russian society who
think that using violence is okay
it's a great danger
it's absolutely unbelievable as you say
and
you mentioned there about knowing people
who are pregnant after rape
how concerned are you that poland has
got such restrictive abortion laws when
obviously so many millions of ukrainian
women are going to poland
yeah unfortunately it's a big problem
because we know that abortion is bent in
poland and it's an additional
uh big problem for ukrainian women but i
know that there is assistance provided
also from other countries and it's it's
a process it's not going that smoothly
but i i know that there is lots of
assistance that is on the way and is
provided to people who are in me in need
including this kind of assistance
and with the need of medical care and
those who are
unfortunately suffering from from rape
but it needs time it cannot be fixed in
one day and it's incredibly dramatic and
sad for all of us
thank you so much for talking so
powerfully to us and this morning it's
such a privilege to get to speak to
people like you and also you know you
said that you can't feel happy anymore
and i really hope that you know in the
future that does change
thank you